If you caught my Direct Message last week,
you heard me explain why we shouldn't let
politics make us crazy, yet the crazy seems
to be ramping up everywhere you look these
days.
This constant onslaught of political bickering
has a very polarizing effect on most people:
The fighting either makes them obsessively
tune in to politics nonstop, or reflexively
tune out of politics altogether . With so
much news and commentary content out there,
if you give me an hour or two of your week
to hear about political science, philosophy,
religion, or anything else we're discussing,
I consider the time you spend here with me
to be a pretty high honor.
Those of you who follow me on social media
outside of YouTube probably saw I spent last
week on a farm with family and friends.
Though I spent most of the week hanging out
with 20 chickens and one duck who think he's
a chicken, I had a couple personal experiences
with actual real life humans which reminded
me why these aren't just abstract ideas we
talk about here.
One of the people on the farm with us was
a trans woman in her 20's, who happened to
have grown up on a pot farm.
She was also an avid hunter and gun rights
enthusiast who was painting her gun locker
bright blue and pink at the time of my visit.
Yes, trans women are sometimes into guns,
but if you judge people as a collective instead
of as an individual, this is the type of person
who will always go ignored.
I also spent time with a farmer who lived
almost 100% off his own land, but he was very
concerned with treating other people fairly
and making sure others had the same opportunity
to succeed which he had.
While his day to day life had a very libertarian
bend to because he provided for himself and
lived on the land, there was no doubt he wanted
there to be assistance for people so they
could one day share in the same opportunity
and pride in work that he has attained.
His live and let live attitude was blended
with his desire to good for others in his
community.
He was a far cry from what some say about
those selfish libertarians, or what others
says about those authoritarian Leftys.
While I was away, I also had a truly awe inspiring
hike up Mt.
Rainier, which is part of the United States
National Park Service.
This park is a great example of a natural
wonder we have in this country which is funded
and protected by the federal government.
You know I'm a small government guy and would
prefer local and state funding, but a place
like Mt.
Ranier, which is so gorgeous and powerful,
should have some federal funding, and I'd
say the same for Yellowstone National Park
or Yosemite.
How much funding, or the best way to pay for
this funding, is the real question in the
debate.
By the way, though, Mt.
Ranier is also funded by state and local organizations,
and I met many great people along the trail
who were volunteering their time and energy
to a place they love so much.
That's called putting your beliefs into action,
not just demanding the government pay for
something with other people's money, which
we talk about here often.
My point is: people are complex, issues are
complex, and finding answers which will satisfy
everyone, always, is almost impossible.
At the same time, not only do we all have
our own strengths and passions, but all also
have our own inconsistencies and blind spots.
Our goal shouldn't be about purity tests so
that people fall in line or adhere to some
false notion of perfection.
Our goal should be the acknowledgement of
our differences so we stand up for the freedom
and liberty that this country was founded
upon.